[Music]
today I thought I would show you like
one or two instructive games back from
my from when I was very very young I
started playing chess when I was seven
years old I played my first treatment
when I was eight years old and by the
time I was eight I was beating my my
parents consistently so I'm gonna show
you guys a picture just to start out
with it's a picture from back when I was
around nine or ten years old this was I
guess 2002 according to my shirts and
from when I was in an elementary school
I was traveling around the country
playing in a lot of national tournaments
and along the way I I won decent number
of trophies some of my trophies were
bigger than others this was about half
my size some sometimes I would I would
not win any trophies and it would be
upsetting but that's part of chess
sometimes you win sometimes you lose and
you have to kind of learn how to cope
with your losses learn from them and
then improve so the game I want to show
is a game from when I was very very
young I was about nine years old I was
playing someone maybe six times my age
at least 50 probably older and at least
twice my size he was at over 6 feet tall
I was probably around 4 feet tall so
maybe not quite twice my size but it was
a very scary opponent because he was
older than me bigger than me but in
chess that doesn't necessarily matter
because in chess it's all about the mind
game his rating his rating was 2,000 my
rating was 1,300 so he was kind of
bigger than me and all aspects rating
age size but I won this game and
sometimes that's the amazing thing about
chess it doesn't matter about your
rating necessarily it matters how you
play over the board and I won this game
in 13 moves
so in this game my opponent played the
Scandinavian anyone heard of the
Scandinavian it's a chess opening
it's also been fine Gold's favorite
pizza and that's a Sicilian
oh it's Scandinavian it should it should
be a pizza but anyway I took the pong he
takes and he developed his queen very
early he was looking to beat me from the
very beginning but the problem with
developing your queen early is it gets
attacked very quickly so my next move
develops a piece and attacks the queen
who can find it
Selina Knight to c3 very good
you guys agree I hope Knight c3
attacking the Queen Queen had to move
you played Queen a5 and now I play d4 so
I'm just looking to to control the
center as best as possible and my
opponent played sort of strangely here
he played c6 not developing a piece not
really doing anything useful he's
blocking his knight from developing
right so I was a little bit confused but
I just focused on my own development I
play Knight to f3 and then he played
Bishop to g4 pinning my knight to the
Queen he's hoping that I touched my
knight so I have to move it but of
course I didn't do that
I played pawn h3 attacking his Bishop
and now black has a choice I want
someone and we'll take a few responses
someone to suggest and move for black
this position yes what would you play is
back ok that's a couple of responses
would anyone do anything else is back
anyone yes
you don't want to play H 5 H 5 even
though it supports the bishop that loses
a bishop and it turns out that there's a
pin along H file so doesn't quite work
in this position there's another
interesting move I want to show you guys
for black which is actually a bad move
which is Queen h5 my opponent didn't
play this but if he did a white it has
an interesting trick it looks like
the Queen is pinning the pond to the
wreck so if I were to take his bishop he
would take my rook however it turns out
this is very good for lights even though
I just lost the rook white to move how
can I take advantage of the fact that
the queen is on h1 this is sort of a bit
complicated but how how can I
perhaps trap the Queen
I think I've perplexed everyone yes yes
92 is a very good move do you agree
Selena g3g 3 knock whites there's
actually 2 good moves for whites in this
position Knight e4 or 92 92 is a great
move because it has a threat which is
unstoppable let's say whatever black
does let's say blacks play some normal
move 97 white to move how do how does
white attack the Queen Knight G 3 who
else agrees Knight G 3
hopefully everyone Knight g3 amazingly
enough the white pieces work together to
control every single square the Queen
can move - the Queen has nowhere to go
all these squares are controlled by the
white pieces the bishop takes away h6
pawn takes away h5 as well as the
Knights other Knight takes away these
two squares upon controls h3 and thus
knight on f3 controls g1 as well and the
Queen's attacks so I would be winning a
queen here h2 is controlled by the
knight yeah forgot one arrow though
there makes sense to everyone
so black would not be able to go into
this line without losing some material
that's a lot of arrows yeah let us go
forward with actual game my opponent
decided to take the knight probably not
the best option usually when you're in a
situation where you're pinning a piece
it's better to keep the pin and the best
move was probably Bishop to h5 just
maintaining the pin trading off the
piece after Bishop take f3 allows my
queen to activates and he trades off one
of his only develop pieces so now white
is ahead and development I have more
control over the center things are going
well for me he played Knight to d7
I played Bishop to c4 developing the
bishop and hoping he doesn't see that
I'm attacking f7 but he saw it he played
Knight to f6 developing and defending a7
I castle and now he plays he 6
so both of us are kind of in the still
in the opening stage still completing
development I develop my Bishop to f4
and he played a very sharp move here he
Castle queenside and this is something
that you guys want to really pay
attention to when you're playing a chess
game whenever you Castle one way and
your opponent castles the other way it's
going to be a more it's going to be a
more attacking game you'll see pawn
storms you'll see attacks you'll see
more sacrifices because white wants to
attack the black King on the Queen side
black wants to attack the White King on
the Kings side so usually in a situation
like this it comes down to who can
attack faster and who can create the
bigger threats so I start with a very
normal centralizing move I start with
rook d1 and now my opponent plays kind
of a an interesting scary-looking move
he was a scary-looking guy so I guess
this move suited his appearance he
played Queen B for fork attacking my
pawn and my bishop both of which are
undefended now I have an option I see a
lot of hands raised even though I didn't
ask any questions yet who wants to guess
what I play it as White's in this
position and we're gonna go around and
we'll just go around see who says what
and then we'll see what I played so
we'll start in the front and then kind
of go in a circle so do you want to
suggest a move Bishop b3 any other
suggestions yes
b3 okay any other suggestions the move
that I play it is probably the trickiest
and only one person said it
Bishop a6 very clever idea so it's a
trick and I'm hoping that it's kind of a
hope move I'm hoping that he makes a
mistake here and and loses right away
I'm really hoping that he takes my
bishop because after pawn takes Bishop
what can White play yeah Luka he takes
he six I was really hoping for this but
he's mm he won't fall into this let's go
back
let me ask you guys what should black
play to counter Bishop a6 any
suggestions I'm gonna show you guys what
he played he played a very very bad move
here pretty much almost as bad as pawn
take bishop you played Knight to b6 now
stay quiet and raise your hand if you
see why it's a bad move for black I call
on quiet people
yes wait to move Queen captures c6 this
pawn on b7 is not defending the c6 fun
because it's pinned and I very simply
take which is not only check it's
checkmate
nothing black can do to get out of check
and it was a blind spot for him he
didn't realize this pawn was pinned
keeping Mike he's 2,000 and he missed
made one so of course I was very excited
after this game I beat someone 700
points higher than me it's not something
you see every day and this game was
actually featured in the newspaper the
following week and the newspaper had
this position with white to move and
check me than one and it's probably
pretty embarrassing for him to to lose
this way especially especially against a
little kid and especially in 13 moves so
going back to this position black should
have seen that White's thread is made in
one and black should have defended
against it with what move Knight B
eights might be possible it's kind of
passive but it does defend and the taxa
Bishop Selena Queen b6 and this is a
move the newspaper actually suggested
that blacks should play Queen b6 here
attacking the bishop to fight in the pot
and keeping an eye on the B to play
so lessons to take away from this game
nobody is invincible even old guys with
big ratings can be beatable if if you
catch them at the right time maybe even
3000 guys that they are they are
certainly beautiful so I want you guys
next time you play someone older than
you or higher either than you don't be
too afraid and usually usually the older
guys are more scared of the younger
people so that should work in your
advantage I played this game around the
same time I was 9 or 10 years old still
young player and again this game I'm
playing old Russian guy old Russian guys
are probably the scariest people to play
in chess because the Russians are known
to be like very historically very good
chess players but this guy unfortunately
also lost to me
very quickly and I was black in this
game he started out with efore and we
went in to a four nights opening they
call it the four nights opening for very
obvious reasons and my opponent
continues he plays Bishop to c4 which
looks like a very normal move and I've
noticed that especially in a lot of kids
tournaments and kids games this position
is incredibly common I I might see this
like close to half the time in kids
games
people love the for tonight's opening
and they love playing this Bishop c4
move it turns out that Black has a very
good response here and black can play
something called the Center for trick so
black to move anyone know the first move
of the Center for trick yes over there
you forgot okay uh yes Luca and I take
you for I think you've seen this before
right after a night a key for this is a
first move in the trick white will take
now black to move and this is a fork
part of the trick
thank you yeah Celina d5 so they call it
the Center for trick because it's tricky
it's a fork and it happens in the center
and I'm winning my piece back even
though I gave away night I'm winning
either in the night or the bishop back
and I'm taking over the center so this
is already pretty good for black my
opponent defends a bishop plays Bishop
b5 I take his Knight and he takes my
pawn on e5 now we reach this position
which it looks like Black is under some
pressure white is pinning my Knights
mine I can't move anywhere and he's
attacking my knight twice it's only
defended once so what can black do here
to not only defend the knight on c6 but
also white black can also fork in this
position so black to move play the best
move yes
Bishop t7 not a bad move but there's a
better move yes Queen d5 this is what we
call a multi-purpose move it's doing a
bunch of things and just one move it's
attacking the Knights attacking the
bishop defending my own Knights and also
just donning the center and now white is
actually in a pickle White's my
opponent's decided to take nights with
check what should I take back with the
Queen or the pawn can shatter that the
pawn of course I don't want to take with
Queen I want to take with pawn the night
is still controlling c6 and now his
knight is smack in the center and I want
to ask you guys a kind of a funny
question what animal is a knight most
like yeah anyone a horse right everyone
gonna say horse I'm gonna beg to differ
a knight is most like an octopus and let
me explain an octopus has how many how
many tentacles is an octopus f8 right
when the knight is in the center of the
board it has eight squares it can move -
so next time you look at your Knights
you should think more about octopuses
octopi then the Knights or then horses
so in this position the knight has eight
different moves is smack in the center I
want you guys to figure out the only
safe square for the Knights because most
of these squares are not not good
squares for the Knights Selena what
would you play Knight g4 this is the
only safe square for the Knights it's
not safe why
okay what does look I think same thing
yeah the bishop can take on g4 but then
the Queen could take back so it turns
out the knight is protected on g4 all
other squares are bad for the Knights
all that all other squares I could take
it very easily but g4 it's only
protected square so it's saved by by the
Queen so let me ask you guys should I
take the knight or do something else in
this position would anyone want to take
the Knights anyone okay good you don't
want to take the knight here because it
would help white activate the Queen so
instead I want you guys to find a move
my next move is actually one of the
strongest moves of the game find the
move for black which prevents whites
from castling it's easy okay see it yes
Queen b5 or a queen c4 okay very
interesting does anyone have any other
suggestions yes bishop basics so it
turns out all of these moves prevent
light from castling because all of them
control this very key f1 square the move
I played was Bishop a6 I wanted to keep
my queen in the center and develop my
bishop now it turns out that the King
can not castle can't castle through
check chess base will yell at you if you
try it doesn't work now this is very
important because I'm preventing white
from doing something that usually you
have to do an opening you have to castle
to get your King safe and now that I've
I've kind of trapped the King in the
center it's a lot easier to attack so
this move Bishop a6 actually allowed me
to win the game in just a few more moves
we're going to keep going Knight to e3
attacking my queen
I played Queen efj I've like could try
and Castle queenside but it would take a
long time to develop the Queen side now
my opponent played a very bad move he
kind of freaked out in this position
you didn't know what to do he couldn't
Castle I don't think he wanted to move
his deep on because I would have a lot
of attackers on it so he fired an even
worse move
he played pawn f3 has anyone been to
abend Feingold lecture never play f3
yeah usually usually you should be very
very careful moving that pawn sometimes
it's okay but very rarely in this
position it's very bad because it
exposes a king and I played a a very
normal but tricky move here I played
Bishop d6 he took my pawn and now I want
you guys to think in this position if
you see it be quiet let other people
think black to move and win the game
some people are very excited well let
others think of that so queen g3 looks
very suspicious at first because the
pawn can take but it turns out you're
exactly right who else was thinking
queen g3 okay some people queen g3 is
what we call an invisible move it looks
impossible but however it it wins a game
by force the pawn has to take it now
what's the final move yes yes
I think everyone can agree bishop take
g3 and amazingly enough the bishops
coordinated extremely well together
taking away all the squares from the
king and the king is left with on its
own so that's what's good about the
Bishop parrot because they work together
the bishops don't overlap each other one
bishop controls the darks wears other
bishop controls the light squares and
the other good thing is keeping the King
in the center if I didn't play this move
Bishop a six and the King wouldn't be
stuck like this so it's very important
that not only do you follow the opening
principles yourself and get your King
safe but sometimes it's good to prevent
your opponent from achieving all of the
principle isn't opening and again we go
back to the idea that even when you're
playing an older player even when it's
an old Russian guy those guys are still
beautiful
if you cannot smart them any questions
okay I think we'll end it there I think
now it's time for for free play so I
hope you guys can apply some lessons and
I'll be walking around to answer any
questions
[Music]